As some of you know, I also teach
the computational photography class.
One question always comes up.
What is the difference between these two
classes and the material covered in it?
There is indeed some overlap
between the classes,
especially in the initial
few modules where we
learn about computing with images and
extracting information from images.
Computational photography is really
about capturing a light from a scene
to record a scene into a photograph or
such other related novel artifact
that showcases the scene.
Image analysis is done to
support the capture and
display of the scene in novel ways.
Some of it's actually about
building newer forms of cameras and
softwares to facilitate that process.
Computer vision is really about
interpreting an analysis of the scene.
That is what is the content of the image
of the scene, who is in there,
what is in the image and
what is happening.
Needless to say, there is overlap and
one can benefit from the other.
I also enjoy both of them and
I do work in research and education in
both these topics because they're about
building intelligence systems and
about actually processing and
analyzing images and photographs.
I'm excited about it,
I look forward to engaging with all of
you on either, or both, of these topics